shelby's with us in Corpus Christi Texas
I shall be how are you I'm Dave thank
you for your time
my question is I'm a new grad I just got
my registered nurse and I'm planning on
going back to school today
or this year unfortunately I've had car
problems in the last six months I have a
2006 Ford Fusion
I spent 2,500 on the car in the last six
months and the current problems that
it's having now I'm going to have to
spend another $3,000 to keep it going
I wouldn't do that what's the car worth
what was so for today Kelley Blue Book
says 4,000 I think you could sell it as
it sits for $4,000 no okay you're so
cool problems the dealership is offering
me 2250 if I buy a car this month
oh yeah bad but that's not that you know
so the car is probably worth as is
probably close to $3,000 then if you
sold it yourself on Craigslist I might
be able to get that much yeah okay and
but and it's obviously a piece of crap
so you need to get rid of it I don't
disagree with it you have any money
I do well here's the thing I thought the
pet car was paid off but was speaking of
my parents they owe $4,200 on it away so
it's they're gone well but I don't want
to give it back to them I know but it's
their call over there yes technically
okay crap and so you just graduated from
nursing school mm-hmm okay and so how
much debt do you have from that I have
no debt I made it through it it's very
good for you and so you're completely
debt free except that your parents owe
money on the car that you're driving yes
okay
how is your parents finances not good
and what do you make a year um when me
and my fiance make 67 okay um I I would
suggest working with your parents to get
this car sold and I don't know what that
means it probably
you guys are going to somebody's going
to write a check to get rid of it is
what it sounds like right yeah I don't
think they're in the position to do that
so it sounds like you're going to come
up with $1,000 to sell this car yes okay
and then you're gonna have no money
right well I have six thousand dollars
that I can make as a down payment
awesome no you don't need a down payment
you need a car payment you didn't call
Dave Ramsey has to go into car on car
debt did you no good I'm glad you did
and I want a reliable one but I don't
can I get a reliable car sure house
dollars oh absolutely
it's not six anymore it's five because
you got to pay to get out of this
parents mess yes so you got a $5,000 car
yeah you can get a decent car for five
thousand bucks because you're not
driving this thing for ten years
drive it until you save up some more
money because you don't have a car
payment and buy a better car correct so
how much content were you thinking of
doing before you called me $500 a month
good lord
okay and so if you didn't if you did
what let's just pretend for a second
let's say you wrote a thousand dollar
check and you sold the piece of crap car
of your parents and got them out of
their mess okay okay we got thirty two
hundred or three thousand bucks for it
or whatever that leaves you about five
thousand dollars to buy a car you buy a
five thousand dollar car and you pay
yourself five hundred dollars a month
for 10 months pay yourself a car payment
okay that'd be another five thousand
dollars wouldn't it it would ten months
from now buy another car with five
thousand dollars cash and the trade of
your five thousand dollar car that's a
ten thousand dollar car now we're
getting into a pretty good car and
that's only ten months away in the
meantime you drive a five thousand
dollar car home and pay yourself a car
payment and you don't go into debt for a
car ever if you want to build wealth
okay
I guess my only concern was with
spending six thousand dollars is that I
would get a hunk of junk you could and
have the same problems where I'm
spending almost as much as the cars
worth you could you don't want it you
don't want to get into what you got into
there that was a piece of garbage you
got into
how long you been drive have all you
been driving this car three years okay
I'll talk about ten months but I would
just drive this $5,000 $5,000 car okay
and you Savior and you pay yourself 500
bucks for 10 months and then you sell
your $5,000 car put $5,000 cash with
that and that's a $10,000 car you with
me yeah by the way you have ten months
later you want to move to a $15,000 car
I'm okay with that
okay so put down ten thousand and then
pay off five thousand is what you're
saying
I'm so confused okay let's try again
real quick I got about 20 seconds I want
you to buy a $5,000 car with no car
payments and for the next 10 months I
want you to pay yourself $500 a month
into a cookie jar in that cookie jar you
will magically have $5,000 10 times 500
like you take that $5,000 you sell your
$5,000 car at the end of 10 points and
with that two together you buy a $10,000
car never have you had a car payment
never was there a down payment we're
done